hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute
live zwar hat sich die russische Armee
aus der Region rund um Kiew
zurückgezogen und ist dort mit ihrem
Angriff gescheitert das ist nun aber
umso gefährlicher für die Menschen in
der Ukraine im Süden und Osten des
Landes denn die neue Offensive der
russischen Armee soll sich auf diese
Region konzentrieren und diese
Satellitenbilder die sollen die
russischen Soldaten auf dem Weg in den
Don Bass zeigen knapp 13 Kilometer lang
soll der Konvoi sein 400 russische
Fahrzeuge die Ukraine fürchtet nun noch
mehr um die Menschen in den Städten und
Dörfern im Süden und Osten denn der
russische Präsident Putin der will
seinem Volk den versprochenen Sieg
präsentieren den Sieg um jeden Preis und
wie hier in mariopol seit Wochen ist
diese Stadt eingekesselt von den
russischen Truppen die Bewohner teils
ohne Wasser ohne Essen ohne Strom der
ukrainische Präsident selensky sprach
von 10.000 Toten und fordert erneut mehr
Waffen um die Blockade mariopuls zu
beenden und auch um diese Offensive im
Osten abwehren zu können und deshalb ist
die Frage heute bei uns kann die Ukraine
Russland stoppen und wenn ihr Fragen
oder Kommentare dazu habt dann schreibt
wie immer gerne per Mail oder direkt in
den Stream ich versuche so viele wie
möglich davon zu stellen denn wir können
heute sprechen mit zwei Experten
zunächst mit dem ehemaligen Nato-General
Egon Rams der Minute ist schönen guten
Abend
guten Abend Frau jung Herr Rams wir
haben eben die Bilder dieses russischen
Konvois gesehen hat die Ukraine denn da
im Süden und Osten wenn da jetzt so viel
russische Truppen natürlich noch mal
zusätzlich dorthin kommen hat die
Ukraine da überhaupt eine Chance
also wenn die ukrainische Streitkräfte
die gleiche Kampfmoral zeigen wie sie
bei der Verteidigung von Kiew gezeigt
haben und das war das erste Ziel der
Russen dann haben sie durchaus Chancen
die Russen auch hier aufzuhalten die
Verstärkung die zurzeit dort angeblich
aufgeklärt sind liegen in der
Größenordnung zwischen 30 und 40.000
Soldaten das ist eine Menge und hört
sich im Augenblick auch nach einer
großen Zahl an aber diese Truppenteile
können ja nicht alle gleichzeitig ins
Gefecht eingeführt werden das heißt auf
die gleiche Art und Weise wie man die
Verteidigung kieft organisiert hat kann
man dieses auch dort tun und sind das
alle Kräfte die Russland dann noch zu
bieten hat oder kommt dann noch mehr
das ist eine Frage die kann ich Ihnen
nicht beantworten da ich keine
Aufklärungsergebnisse über
möglicherweise aus der Tiefe
nachgeführte Kräfte habe es hat vor
einigen Tagen Gerüchte gegeben dass auch
aus anderen Teilen Russlands noch Kräfte
in die Nähe der Ukraine verlegt werden
sollen diese sind aber offensichtlich
bisher noch nicht aufgeklärt und auch
die Möglichkeiten russlandskräfte
nachzuführen dürften nicht unbegrenzt
sein
ja und nach dem Rückzug eben aus der
Region um Kiew sehen wir nun also diesen
militärischen Fokus auf die Ost- und
Südukraine gerichtet was genau ist denn
dort das Ziel der Russen was genau
konkret wollen sie da erreichen
also ich stecke nicht im Kopf des
russischen Generalstabes oder von
Wladimir Putin trotzdem erwarte ich dass
man versuchen wird die beiden ablaste
lukansk gondon jetzt komplett zu erobern
um damit die beiden von Putin
anerkannten Republiken oder
Teilrepubliken praktisch als ich sage
das mal einen kleinen Sieg zu verkünden
der möglicherweise mit Blick auf die
Parade die am 9 mai in London in Moskau
stattfinden wird auf dem Roten Platz
stattfinden wird dann als Sieg verkündet
werden wird dass man diese beiden
Regionen befreit hat und dann könnte es
möglicherweise weitergehen weiterhin auf
mariopull und dann Richtung Krim um dort
die entsprechende Landbrücke zu
schließen und auf diese Art und Weise zu
sagen und diese Teile gehören uns
und sie haben mariopol auch angesprochen
wir sehen es auch gerade auf einer Karte
neben ihnen die Regionen die sie
sprachen die Landbrücke und die
Verbindung zur Krim aber mariopol wo
auch jetzt gerade in diesem Moment
natürlich so viele Menschen also
eingekesselt sind von den russischen
Truppen warum ist diese Stadt so wichtig
für Russland
also das ist ein großer Hafen für die
Ukraine am Asowschen Meer und von daher
die Hafenstädte spielen an der
Schwarzmeerküste eine Rolle das gleiche
Aussage gilt für Odessa auf Odessa hat
man sich bisher noch nicht konzentriert
aber das könnte wenn die Erfolge
tatsächlich dazu führen die gewünschten
Erfolge der Russen tatsächlich dazu
führen dass man die Landbrücke bis zur
Krim schließt dann wäre ein mögliches
weiteres Angriffsziel wäre die
Hafenstadt Odessa
und es gibt nun also auch berichte heute
über einen möglichen chemiewaffenangriff
in mariopol also es soll das ist alles
nicht bestätigt von unabhängigen Quellen
aber laut ukrainischer Seite soll eine
russische Drohne eine giftige Substanz
auf ukrainische Soldaten und Zivilisten
abgeworben abgeworfen haben das
behauptet zumindest das ukrainische
Regiment das in mariopult kämpft die
pro-russischen Separatisten aus Donezk
die weisen diese Vorwürfe zurück glauben
Sie das so was denkbar wäre
das ist eine sehr schwierige Frage weil
uns fehlen im Augenblick dafür die
Beweise und da Mario Puller
weitestgehend eingeschlossen ist wird es
auch keine Möglichkeit geben dieses von
neutraler Seite her zu überprüfen das
heißt wir haben die Aussagen der beiden
Kriegsparteien dem also Regiment in
mariopol selber und den Separatisten und
diese Aussagen sind widersprüchlich ich
hoffe ich sage das mit aller
Deutlichkeit ich hoffe dass ein solcher
Einsatz von chemischen Kampfstoffen dort
nicht stattgefunden hat denn das wäre
eine neue Grenze die überschritten würde
und erneut ein Kriegsverbrechen ist
eigentlich auch Mitglied des sogenannten
chemiewaffenabkommens und von daher
sollte man sich daran halten und nicht
noch ein weiteres Abkommen brechen wobei
ich natürlich auch darauf hinweisen muss
dass beispielsweise in Syrien die Russen
zumindest Sadat bei dem Einsatz von
Chemiewaffen assistiert haben von daher
es ist nicht zu 100% auszuschließen
bedürft aber noch der Bestätigung einem
Jahr hat es eine neue Qualität
lassen Sie uns noch mal ganz konkret
auch auf die Chancen der Ukrainer jetzt
natürlich schauen der Ukraine gegenüber
Russland wie wichtig welche Rolle später
zum Beispiel Aufklärung durch
Satellitenbilder wie wir sie auch am
Anfang der Sendung gesehen haben wie
wichtig ist das für die Ukraine solche
Informationen natürlich zu haben
also ich bin der Auffassung dass die
Ukraine diese Informationen aus allen
Quellen die zur Verfügung stehen das
sind amerikanische Satellitensysteme das
sind private Satellitensysteme in dieses
Thema hat sich auch Elon Musk
eingeschaltet es gibt von enorm Musk in
Mario Puls zum Beispiel eine
Bodenstation die offensichtlich noch in
Betrieb ist von daher dass es
ausgesprochen wichtig weil damit die
beurteilungsfähigkeit der ukrainische
Streitkräfte deutlich gesteigert wird
und man hat die Möglichkeit auch
Bewegungen von russischen Truppen ich
sage das mal langfristigen über einen
längeren Zeitraum zu sehen zu beurteilen
und dann die entsprechende militärischen
Gegenmaßnahmen dazu zu treffen von daher
ohne die sich sag mal Augen aus dem
Weltall wäre es ausgesprochen schwierig
wir haben eine Frage aus dem Chat direkt
an Sie von Flavia Ricci sie schreibt
Herr Rams wie könnten nato-reaktionen
auf einen möglichen russischen
chemieangriff aussehen also noch mal
kurz der Bezug auf den auf die ja auf
die Meldung darüber dass es eventuell
ein chemiewaffenangriff gegeben haben
könnte in mariopol
also wir wissen dass die NATO sich
darauf geeinigt hat nicht einzugreifen
sondern sich auf die Verteidigung des
nahtoderatoriums zu konzentrieren das
heißt die NATO unmittelbar militärisch
kann dort auch nicht eingreifen das ist
von den Regeln her so bedauerlich aber
man sollte diese Regeln einhalten um
nicht eine Kriegsgefahr für andere NATO
starten beispielsweise in den baltischen
Staaten darauf zu beschwören
die einzige Möglichkeit darauf zu
reagieren ist erneut die Möglichkeit mit
Sanktionen und Verschärfung von
Sanktionen zu reagieren und es wäre
vielleicht auch dann an entsprechendes
entsprechende wichtige Beurteilung mit
Blick auf die Diskussion die wir ja
zurzeit haben bezüglich von
Waffenlieferungen auch aus Deutschland
und noch einmal zurück auch zu den
Chancen Möglichkeiten der Ukraine sich
jetzt dazu verteidigen immer wieder war
jetzt auch in der Vergangenheit die
Moral der ukrainischen Truppen der
russischen Truppen diskutiert worden was
denken Sie also wie sieht es aktuell aus
natürlich auch um diese Moral auf der
Seite der beiden kampfparteien weil der
dieser Krieg geht ja jetzt schon auch
eine ganze Weile
also die Moral auf der Kampfmoral auf
der ukrainischen Seite Stufe ich
weiterhin als sehr hoch ein auch wenn
man dabei berücksichtigen muss dass zum
Beispiel der Fall von mariopool eine
psychologische Wirkung auf die
ukrainischen Truppen und auf die
ukrainische Bevölkerung haben wird aber
ich denke dass der Präsident selenski
auch mit seinen Ansprachen an sein Volk
und auch an seine Streitkräfte hier den
richtigen Weg geht was denen ich nenne
das mal Informationskrieg zwischen
Russland und der Ukraine angeht
wir haben festgestellt bei den Angriffen
rund um Kiew und auch in anderen
Bereichen dass die Kampfmoral der
russischen Soldaten deutlich niedriger
ist das hat auch zu den Erfolgen der
ukrainischen Streitkräfte geführt und
ich gehe mal davon aus dass auch für die
neu zugeführten Kräfte oder für die
Kräfte die aus dem Norden in Richtung
Osten bzw Süden verlegt worden sind die
Kampfmoral bisher nicht gesteigert ist
ganz im Gegenteil die Soldaten die in
Kiew und Umgebung im Einsatz gewesen
sind abgezogen worden sind jetzt wieder
neu in den Einsatz geschickt werden
dadurch moralisch wahrscheinlich nicht
besser werden und von daher sehe ich
hier weiterhin eine durchaus respektable
Überlegenheit die ukrainische
Streitkräfte
Youtube fragt sie wie hoch schätzt der
General die Qualität der russischen
Truppen ein die Putin noch nicht
eingesetzt hat hält er gut ausgebildete
Streitkräfte zurück und ich würde auch
gerne noch anschließen die Mobilisierung
der Reservisten die jetzt also auch
passieren sollen Russland wie wie steht
es um deren Moral also diese zwei Fragen
an Sie
also ich darf mal mit dem zweiten Teil
der Frage anfangen Stichwort Reservisten
das sind Soldaten die eine russische
Streitkräften in den letzten zehn Jahren
gedient haben und die jetzt wieder
aktiviert werden ich kann mir gut
vorstellen das russische Soldaten
nachdem sie ihren Dienstzeit um gehabt
haben froh gewesen sind dass sie nach
Hause kommen zu ihren Familien kommen
und von daher ich sag mal nicht
unbedingt begeistert sind jetzt in diese
Auseinandersetzung hineingezogen werden
indem sie wieder mobilisiert werden von
daher beurte ich auch da wenn auch der
Ausbildungsstand gut sein mag auch die
Kampfmoral nicht als sonderlich hoch von
daher muss man abwarten wenn diese
Kräfte eingeführt werden wie sich dieses
dann entsprechend zeigen wird
der andere Teil der Frage ist ein
bisschen schwieriger zu beantworten
die Russen haben im militärbezeug West
das ist der der an die NATO-Staaten
angrenzt durchaus gut ausgebildete und
gut ausgerüstete Truppenteile sie haben
aber auch schon für die Offensive auf
die Ukraine Truppenteile beispielsweise
aus dem Kaukasus oder beispielsweise aus
dem militärbezug oder Bezirk Novosibirsk
Militärbezirk Ost dabei geführt und wie
die Situation dort in der
kampfeinstellung der Ausbildung und auch
der Modernität der Ausrüstung ist wie
schwierig zu beurteilen es ist bekannt
dass die Soldaten und die Truppenteile
die Militär Bezirk weststationiert sind
einen höheren Ausrüstungsstand und
besseren Ausrüstungsstand haben von
denen sind bis aber hier bisher nur
relativ weniger eingesetzt was damit zu
erklären ist dass diese mit Masse in den
natogrenzen gegenüberliegen und das
Putin möglicherweise diese Flanke nicht
frei machen will weil er möglicherweise
die Handlungsweise der NATO falsch
einschätzt
und was glauben Sie wann soll diese
Großoffensive im Osten dann richtig
starten wie lange könnte sowas dauern
also ich rechne damit in den nächsten
Tagen es hat Aussagen gegeben in den in
den letzten ich sag mal Tagen wonach
Experten gesagt dann das könnte nach
Ostern passieren man sollte dabei auf
den Kalender gucken Ostern bei uns und
Oster in Russland sind zwei verschiedene
Tage die Liegen eine Woche auseinander
und ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass
unser Experten davon gesprochen haben
dass dieses nach dem russischen
Osterfest erfolgen würde sondern ich
sage mal innerhalb der nächsten drei
vier vielleicht fünf Tage wird diese
Angriff starten
vielen Dank für Ihre Einschätzung heute
Abend an den ehemaligen Nato-General
Egon Rams
gerne herzlichen Dank
und die Ukraine die fordert nun also mit
Nachdruck noch also immer wieder
Waffenlieferung nun umso mehr um sich
verteidigen zu können und vor allem
fordern sie sogenannte schwere Waffen
wie zum Beispiel Panzer Deutschland hat
bislang nein dazu gesagt aber nun
fordert auch die deutsche
Außenministerin Annalena baerbock das
Deutschland schwere Waffen liefern
sollte was Deutschland womöglich bereit
wäre zu liefern laut einer internen
Liste der Regierung die Merian mehreren
Medien vorliegt das haben meine Kollegin
Laura Rosinus und Maike fellath
zusammengefasst
der Krieg in der Ukraine dauert an das
Land fordert deshalb Waffen und
Deutschland ist bereits zu liefern
zumindest einen Teil laut einer internen
Liste der Bundesregierung von
vergangener Woche will Deutschland
verschiedene Waffentypen an die Ukraine
liefern die Liste liegt im Portal the
pioneer und dem Spiegel vor darauf
stehen unter anderem 500
Flugabwehrraketen des Typs Dinger wird
seit den 1990ern bei der Bundeswehr
eingesetzt kann sowohl an hubschrauber-
3000 Panzerfäuste sie können 70 cm
dicken Panzerstahl oder Stahlbetonwände
bis zu 24 cm durchdringen und Ziele in
Entfernung von bis zu 400 Metern
beschießen
außerdem auf der Liste 2053
ältere Bodenluft raketens Trailer aus
alten DDR-Beständen die Flugabwehrrakete
wurde in den 1970er Jahren in der
Sowjetunion entwickelt und kann
Flugzeuge in 2300 Metern Höhe treffen
auch dabei 100 Maschinengewehre MG3 das
MG3 ist das standardmaschinengewehr bei
vielen Einsätzen der Bundeswehr
und 1000 Panzer abwehrminen und mehr als
13 Millionen schussmunition sollen an
die Ukraine geliefert werden
ob diese Waffen der Ukraine überhaupt
helfen und was sie eigentlich von der EU
fordern darüber können wir jetzt
sprechen mit Gustav gressel er arbeitet
am European Council und vorhin relations
beschäftigt sich dort vor allem mit
Sicherheitspolitik und militärstrategien
guten Abend Herr kressel
solche Waffen wie eben im Beitrag
gezeigt würden die der Ukraine überhaupt
reichen um sich zu verteidigen
ja also sie würden ihr helfen aber das
Problem ist es alleine machen
schultergestützte Waffen natürlich
dass das Fehlen nicht aus also hier
würde die Berichterstattung bei uns oder
das Bewusstsein für diesen Krieges in
erster Linie geprägt dass das was wir in
den sozialen Medien sehen und das sind
meistens irgendwann Dresden die in
Städten sich zu Verteidigung einrichten
und dort mit Schulter geschützten Waffen
kämpfen aber das Problem ist dass
berichtet ja nur dort wo wir in Städten
sind weil dort Hotels sind weil dort
Zivilisten sind die Filmen und weil dort
Reporter sind die berichten aber im
Umland eben im Land außerhalb der Städte
da wird er normale mechanisierte Kampf
geführt der Kampf der Verwundungen
waffenpanzer Schützenpanzer Artillerie
da wird verzögerungskampf geführt damit
angegriffen und das ist für die Ukraine
überlebenswichtig diese mechanisierten
Reserven die sie hat auch neu zu bilden
bzw zu erhalten ohne die wir hier schon
eingekesselt ohne die wir gerade schon
eingekesselt und dafür braucht sie einen
ständigen zu
auch von schweren Waffen also von
kampfwahnsinn von Schützenpanzern von
natalie-systemen der entsprechenden
Munition dafür und und natürlich auch
schweren fliegerarbeitsystemen die also
über die 3000 Meter Marke hinaufgehen
bei Youtube fragt sich dazu ist es jetzt
nicht schon fast zu spät schwere Waffen
zu liefern die Waffen müssen doch erst
einmal die lange Strecke bis in den
Osten bzw Süden der Ukraine gebracht
werden in einer Woche ist es zu spät
ja also für viele Dinge die die
Bundeswehr hat ist es ist es natürlich
spät oder viele Dinge die in Deutschland
hat oder hergestellt werden wer es jetzt
spät wenn sie in der Schlacht um den Dom
was jetzt eingreifen wollen das liegt
weniger an der Transportstrecke also die
natürliche Nachschublinie für die
Ukraine selber ist ja auch die
ostwächs-west-achse weil die meisten
Depots die meisten
Lager und auch die meisten Kasernen der
Ukraine in der westprodukraine sind das
hat mit dem sowjetischen Erbe zu tun
damals war die Sowjet Armee auf
sozusagen auf eine Offensive gegen
Westen ausgerichtet daher die meiste
Infrastruktur dort aber das Problem ist
wenn es sich nicht um Gerät handelt dass
die Ukraine schon kennt und schon
ausgebildete Soldaten drauf hat oder auf
einem sehr ähnlichen System dann ist es
bei komplexeren Waffensystemen braucht
man dann eine Zeit erstens mal um die
Leute also die die Mannschaften darauf
auszubilden und zweitens um die die
logistische Infrastruktur schaffen bei
so einem Panzer geht er im Grunde die
ganze Zeit etwas kaputt bzw muss
überwacht werden und Sie brauchen
wartungsmannschaften die sich mit dem
Gerät auskennen die die Ersatzteile
zumindest die die normalen
Verschleißteile die wir zu einem Panzer
halt anfallen bei der Hand haben und
dann entsprechende entsprechende
Reparaturen noch schnell vornehmen
können und das braucht eigentlich weit
mehr Zeit als der Transport
die diese Zeit für die Schlacht um den
donbos hat man nicht mehr aber das
Problem ist dieser Krieg wird er mit der
Schlacht von den Donbass jetzt nicht
vorbei sein sondern das ist eine Etappe
die russischen politischen Ziele das
ganze Land zu unterwerfen die haben sich
nicht geändert man geht es nur
militärisch langsamer und in einer
anderen Reihenfolge an in dem Sinn ist
ist vieles der bedenken dass es jetzt
schon uns fehlt wäre die Treffen im
Grunde jetzt nur auf die akute Phase
dieser einen Schlacht zu aber mittel und
langfristig gäbe sich natürlich er ich
natürlich schon Möglichkeiten die
Ukraine auch zu unterstützen
eine Frage passend dazu bei Youtube was
genau dauert denn bei der Ausbildung so
lange bei der Ausbildung für dieses
Gerät die grundlegende Bedienung von
fahrzeugwaffensystem oder der richtige
taktische Einsatz
den richtigen taktischen Einsatz den den
können die Ukraine meistens schon also
das wäre natürlich fertig ausgebildete
mordschützen also das Equivalent zu den
Bundeswehr oder Panzer Offizieren oder
Artillerie Offizieren die wissen den
taktischen Einsatz solche Waffensysteme
natürlich wieder geht aber das
Spezifikum der entsprechenden Waffe das
kennen sie nicht und die technischen die
technischen Gegebenheiten bei dieser
Waffe nicht dann ist natürlich ein also
je nach Waffensystem anders also ein
Beispiel ein Schützenpanzer Marder ist
es weit weniger komplex als zum Beispiel
ein Fliegerabwehr Panzer Gepard je
nachdem wie komplex das System ist ist
es dauert es manchmal kürzer manchmal
länger die Mannschaften darauf
auszubilden und die die
wartungsmannschaften darauf auszubilden
man muss ja da denken die Leute müssen
sozusagen ja nicht nur nach einer
Einweisung kurz wissen wie das Ding
funktioniert die müssen unter
erheblichen dieses System bedienen das
heißt in ihrer Bedienung und ihr in
ihrer Diagnose wenn du mal was schief
läuft schon schon dementsprechend
gefestigt sein dass sie unter Stress und
unter Extrembedingungen das auch
anwenden bzw richtig anhaben können
dass das braucht einfach seine Zeit auch
wenn wenn die Ukraine natürlich hier
sicherlich sehr motiviert und
tatkräftig zupacken werden ist ist das
sozusagen bei einfacheren Kampf und
gefechtsfahrzeugen sind Erfahrungswert
auch bei anderen systemeneinführungen in
den anderen Ländern dass das mindestens
vier Monate dauert und auch bis die
logistische Infrastruktur aufgebaut ist
wenn wir bei komplexeren
fliegerabwehrsystemen würde es noch
deutlich länger dauern
und vielleicht das mir das auch alle
noch mal ganz konkret verstehen also zum
einen fordert die Ukraine Waffen zum
anderen kann die Ukraine auch Waffen
selbst kaufen gibt es da einen
Unterschied wie läuft so ein Prozess
genau ab
ja also in der Tat viele viele Waffen
würde die Ukraine gerne kaufen die die
möchte es nicht geschenkt haben da ist
es halt erstens mal den Unterschied ist
sind diese Waffen werden die ab
Hersteller gekauft
und hat er Hersteller freie
Kapazitäten die zu liefern wie zum
Beispiel diese Panzerabwehrwaffen
Matador
oder RGB 90 wie sie wie sie heißen da
hat der Hersteller eine freie Kapazität
gehabt die Waffen werden laufend
hergestellt und die Ukraine kauft sie da
muss im Grunde
das Wirtschaftsministerium bzw einem
einhellverfahren bei einigen Systemen
der Bundessicherheitsrat zustimmen und
dann kann man sie abkaufen schwieriger
wird zum Beispiel wenn der Hersteller
sie produziert aber für einen anderen
Kunden also zum Beispiel es gibt in
Deutschland einen fliegersystem das
gerade für Ägypten gebaut wird und kurz
vor der Auslieferung steht da kann man
natürlich nicht einfach kann
dahersteller zu meiner nicht sagen
darüber verfügen und sagen die verkauft
jetzt an wen anderen sondern da müsste
die Bundesregierung einen ausstellen
dass also eine Belieferung der Ukraine
eine dringliche Belieferung der Ukraine
nationalen Interesse Deutschlands
Sicherheitsinteresse Deutschlands wäre
weil ohne dieses deutsche
Sicherheitsinteresse kommen sie aus
bestehenden Verträgen nicht raus also da
ist schon der Staat sozusagen anders
gefordert und dann stellt sie natürlich
die Frage bei gebrauchgerät ist das
Gebrauchtgerät steht es beim Hersteller
herum also hat die Bundeswehr schon das
Gerät ausgeschieden und ist nicht mehr
der Eigentümer dann kann ich natürlich
rascher verkaufen so es in einem Zustand
ist in dem es auch verwendungsfähig ist
wenn es natürlich modernisiert werden
muss oder erst erst gewartet werden muss
dann dauert das auch länger oder ist die
Bundeswehr da Eigentümer dann müsste
dieses Gerät natürlich auch mit
Zustimmung des Verteidigungsministeriums
ausgeschieden und abverkauft werden was
angesichts der Materiallage der
Bundeswehr die ja auch nicht sehr rosig
ist da auch immer für Zähneknirschen
sorgt
ja dazu kommen wir auch gleich noch mal
zu sprechen ich würde gerne noch kurz
die Stimmung auch ein paar Kommentare
bei uns aus dem Stream rausgreifen
Nemesis 2006 schreibt die Waffen
verlängern den Krieg und das Leid der
Menschen nur klares Nein Friedrich III
schreibt hingegen tja während die
Ukraine in die EU in die NATO
aufgenommen worden müssten wir darüber
nicht reden ob wir Waffen liefern müssen
und mit jemand wie Putin kann man nicht
reden also ist das richtig Systeme zur
Verteidigung zu schicken und nachdem was
man bisher gesehen hat
befürworte ich das also unterschiedliche
Meinungen bei uns im Stream sie haben es
angesprochen es braucht also die
zustimmungsverteidigungsministeriums es
gibt auch tatsächlich scheinbar ein
bisschen unterschiedliche Meinungen
innerhalb der Bundesregierung die
Außenministerin wir haben es in der
Sendung schon erwähnt hat sich geäußert
und auch der Bundeskanzler wir haben
dazu auch zwei Aussagen von den beiden
und hören dann mal rein
die Ukraine braucht weiteres
militärisches Material vor allen Dingen
auch schwere Waffen und jetzt ist keine
Zeit für Ausreden sondern jetzt ist Zeit
für Kreativität und Pragmatismus wir
haben in der Vergangenheit die Ukraine
mit Waffen ausgerüstet und ausgestattet
in Bezug auf
Panzerabwehrraketen auf
Luftabwehrraketen Munition und vieles
andere und wir werden die Ukraine auch
weiter unterstützen das tun wir in einer
engen Zusammenarbeit mit all unseren
Freunden mit denen wir uns da absprechen
und da wird es keine Alleingänge sondern
immer nur gemeinsames und sorgfältig
abgewogenes Handeln geben
gemeinsames Handeln muss es natürlich
auch in der Bundesregierung geben also
zwischen
Verteidigungsministerium aus Ministerium
und wie sieht das aus also wie glauben
Sie wie schätzen Sie das ein die
Außenministerin die also schwere Waffen
fordert und Verteidigungsministerium was
bislang auch teilweise zurückhaltend war
wie passt das zusammen
die Grünen waren hier eigentlich voll im
Wahlkampf schon
progressiver also wenn man sich an
Arbeitsbesuch im repool erinnert wurde
danach ja auch war vonlieferungen für
die Ukraine
befürwortet hat dann unter schweren
Beschuss innenpolitisch kam da muss man
natürlich sonst sagen wer hat das schon
recht gehabt damals und es war zwar
innenpolitisch nicht populär aber es war
sachlich sicher richtig was er gesagt
hat und diese Trennlinie die die Kraft
jetzt natürlich auch wieder aus
wo ich wo ich halt leider auch dem dem
Kanzler widersprechen muss und ich
glaube das ist jetzt eine Sache die
wirklich am Kanzleramt und am Kanzler
liegt also mir liegen Bericht von
europäischen Staaten vor und jetzt nicht
der Ukraine sondern NATO Mitgliedern und
Mitgliedern der Europäischen Union die
also auch in Kanzleramt angefragt haben
ob sie zum Beispiel jetzt Kampffahrzeuge
aufkaufen können aus ehemaligen
Beständen der schwer über die wir jetzt
im Ukraine Kontext reden und das war
schon vor Monaten damit jeder Ukraine
zum Beispiel Schützenpanzer abgeben
können die die Ukraine schon in ihrem
Bestand hat wo es kein Training braucht
die die Ukrainer alle schon kennen und
diese Anfragen von NATO-Partnern von
EU-Mitgliedstaaten blieben bis dato
komplett
unbeantwortet und das führt natürlich
dann bei unseren Verbündeten schon zu
ein bisschen zu einem Kopf kratzen wo
man sich fragt was geht davor aber
natürlich stellt sich auch die Frage wie
auch hier von Michael keiner bei uns bei
Youtube wenn Deutschland jetzt Waffen an
die Ukraine abgibt kann sich Deutschland
dann im Notfall überhaupt noch
verteidigen
ja das kommt darauf an von welchem
System wir reden und wie viel da davon
im Bestand sind also
jetzt jetzt zum Beispiel Kampfpanzer
Leopard 2 geht definitiv nicht weil weil
wir da in einem akuten unterbestand in
der Bundeswehr sind die Bundeswehr
erwartet auf modernisierte und
aufgerüstete Leopard 2 ihrerseits und
hat einen zu knappen Bestand
beim schützenband samada ist es so dass
da 100 Geräte beim Hersteller stehen die
die Bundeswehr schon ausgeschieden hat
wo sie also schon das nicht mehr
Eigentümer ist sondern die Geräte schon
schon abgegeben hat
da kann man natürlich schwerlich
argumentieren die Bundeswehr braucht
diese für die eigene Landesverteidigung
weil wenn Sie diese bräuchte dann hätte
sie nicht ausgeschieden also das hat das
hängt von System zu System ab
auch andere Waffensysteme die
Deutschland für den Export baut auch da
kann man überlegen ob man hier zum
Beispiel sich abspricht entweder mit
anderen eu-natome Mitgliedstaaten die
Gerät schnell abgeben können an die
Ukraine ob man denen sozusagen eine eine
bevorzugte Behandlung gibt dass das
schnell geschehen kann oder oder wenn es
sich mit den entsprechenden Fristen
ausgeht ob man dann die Ukraine dran
nimmt das kann man das kann man alles
erwägen und und beurteilen ohne dass die
Einsatzbereitschaft der Bundeswehr
selber Mitleidenschaft gezogen wird denn
wie gesagt Waffensysteme die sie bis
jetzt nicht gekauft hat oder
ausgeschieden hat die werden sie
eigentlich oder die sollten Sie
eigentlich nicht besonders berühren
sie haben die Kampfpanzer angesprochen
und welche schweren Waffen die Ukraine
konkret fordert was Deutschland
theoretisch zur Verfügung stellen könnte
und in welchem Zustand aber auch diese
schweren Waffen sind dazu ein Beitrag
von Michael fellath und Laura Rosinus
zuletzt hat die Ukraine nach 100
gebrauchten Schützenpanzern vom Typ
Marder gefragt diese wurden 1972 in der
Bundeswehr eingeführt die von der
Bundeswehr ausgemusterten Panzer müssten
für einen Einsatz in der Ukraine
generalüberholt werden das dauert Monate
die Idee war deshalb dass die Bundeswehr
eigene mörderpanzer an die Ukraine
abgibt und entstehende Lücken im
kommenden Jahr mit den generalüberholten
Mardern auffüllt
Verteidigungsministerin Christine
Lambrecht habe ukrainischen Quellen
zufolge jedoch abgelehnt und
argumentiert dass die Panzer in
nato-aufgaben gebunden sein die Ukraine
hätte gerne auch Panzer vom Typ gepaart
die sind mit Flugabwehrkanonen
ausgestattet
auch Panzer vom Typ Leopard stehen auf
der Wunschliste der Rüstungskonzern
Rheinmetall kündigte an bis zu 50
Leopard 1 Panzer an die Streitkräfte der
Ukraine liefern zu können bei den
Kampfpanzern handelt es sich um
Altbestände anderer Armeen die
Bundeswehr nutzt längst das
Nachfolgemodell Leopard 2
[Musik]
eine kleine Korrektur der Beitrag war
von meiner Kollegin Sarah lasar und von
Michael fellert das soll hier nicht
untergehen jetzt haben wir also eben
gerade diese unterschiedlichen
kampfpanzertypen gehört wir haben auch
gehört dass ein Rüstungsunternehmen das
Panzer hat bislang aber die nicht
abgeben konnte die Bundesregierung
darauf nicht reagiert haben soll wie ist
das einzuschätzen
ja das ist in der Tat verwunderlich also
es gibt es liegen auch mir Informationen
vor dass es hier einfach keine
Entscheidung zu den gibt dass die die
Produzenten in Deutschland schon
Anfragen bei der Bundesregierung weil es
dir verschiedenste Anfragen haben
einerseits direkt von der Ukraine
andererseits auch Anfragen von EU und
nat- und Nachbarstaaten die gerne
ablösen hätten für Ihr Gerät und um Ihr
Gerät ihrerseits in Ukraine zu liefern
und
weil wir davon Fristen geredet haben die
gebraucht werden um
Fahrzeuge zu modernisieren wieder in
Schuss zu bringen
der Hersteller kann er nur anfangen wenn
er weiß dass er die Dinge verkaufen kann
und jeder Monat der nicht Entscheidung
der da verstreicht und wir sind bald
zwei Monate im Krieg der addiert sich ja
noch einmal auf die Wartezeiten drauf
das heißt da wäre eigentlich einmal
Geschwindigkeit
angesagt die die Mara Schützenpanzer
wurden sagen gesprochen da ist es zum
Beispiel so dass nicht alle dieser 100
komplett kaputt wären einige wären
durchaus schon einmal für Trainings und
Schulungszwecke also für die Ausbildung
der Besatzung die ich auch angesprochen
habe die auch noch einmal einige Monate
dauern würde zu gebrauchen und
wenn man hier sozusagen das Okay geben
würde dann kann man mit dem Hersteller
da einen gestaffelten Plan ausarbeiten
wie man Training Renovierung von vom
Kampffahrzeugen Instandhaltung sozusagen
in eine gute Zeit Leiste bastelt damit
man dann ein verwendungsfähiges Produkt
am Ende an die Ukraine liefert aber aber
das nicht entscheiden dazu das hält im
Grunde nur auf und das bietet eine
Unsicherheit
die die weder der Ukraine nach
Deutschland in diesem Zustand sonderlich
hilft
ich lese übrigens auch viel Sorge bei
uns im Stream und möchte das jetzt auch
gerne noch mal aufgreifen also Sorge in
der Form Beispiel aber davon einige
Stimmen Max Ludwig bei Youtube schreibt
könnte das Niefern schwerer Waffen nicht
von Russland als Einmischung in den
Krieg betrachtet werden und somit zu
unabsehbaren Folge Reaktionen seitens
Putin führen
nein also das Liefern von Waffen selber
nicht
der eine Einmischung unsererseits in den
Krieg direkt würde das das da reden wir
jetzt hier jetzt auch nicht von
Flugverbotszonen und ähnlichen sondern
von der Lieferung von Waffen da ist es
übrigens rechtlich völlig egal ob Sie
eine Panzerfaust oder eine Pistole oder
ein Kampfflugzeug liefern also die
Komplexität ist nicht Teil des das
politischen oder rechtlichen Problems
was
sicherlich Teil des Problems ist wobei
das bei Landfahrzeugen an und für sich
recht einfach zu trennen ist man muss
sehr darauf aufpassen dass man dass man
Einsatz und Überführung genau
voneinander trennt das wäre zum Beispiel
bei Kampfflugzeugen oder bei Drohnen
größerer Reichweite wäre das eher eine
haarige Sache also die Überführung ist
dass ich das Gerät in der Ukraine
verkauft und irgendwo der ukrainischen
Armee übergebe in der Ukraine dann
gehört denen und dann können Sie es ein
und der Einsatz ist eben dann wenn das
Gerät
militärisch in den Einsatz geht spricht
schießt und dann eben auf auf russische
Streitkräfte oder oder
Flugkörper oder Flugzeuge wirkt bei
einem Flugzeug wäre das zum Beispiel
dann oder hat man es in der
Vergangenheit so gelöst dass man eigene
überführungspiloten
anstellt die das Flugzeug in das
unbewaffnet in das Empfängerland
verbringen auch während eines Krieges
das ist schon öfter in der Geschichte
vorgekommen damit sozusagen die andere
kriegsführende Partei nicht sagen kann
diese diese Flugzeuge hätten Einsätze
vom Territorium der NATO aus geflogen
man muss aber auch sagen also auch die
Russische Föderation liefert Waffen und
Munition an Kriegsparteien die mit
nato-streitkräften zum Teil im Krieg
oder in einer kriegerischen
Auseinandersetzung verwickelt sind und
das das inkludiert auch komplexe
Waffensysteme bis hinauf zu
Kampfflugzeugen inklusive der Piloten
also da sozusagen packen wir jetzt halt
Russland auch bei bei den Mitteln die es
vorher schon eingesetzt hat gegen uns
und das muss dann der Kreml abkönnen
dass diese diese Mittel dann auch gegen
die Interessen des Kremls Mal eingesetzt
werden
zum Schluss noch die Frage viele
Experten und Expertinnen hatten am
Anfang einen schnellen russischen Sieg
vorhergesagt wie sehen Sie denn die
Chancen jetzt für die Ukraine da
überhaupt noch dem ganzen ja dem ganzen
entgegen zu kommen dem ganzen dagegen
anzukommen im Süden und Osten wo jetzt
diese Großoffensive also starten soll
ja also die diogene hat eine eine
Offensive mit ähnlich starken Kräften
schon einmal überlebt es wird natürlich
jetzt im Osten schwieriger weil diese
Kräfte viel konzentrierter auftreten
aber allein dass die Ukraine schon steht
dass Russland ist nicht geschafft hat
Kiew einzunehmen oder Kiew Einzug
pressen ist er schon ein Erfolg für die
ukrainische Armee die die Lieferung von
schultergestützten Waffen also Stinger
Panzerfaust oder oder Javelin durch die
USA am Anfang des Krieges passierte er
vor dem Hintergrund dass man glaubte in
wenigen Wochen ist der Krieg in der in
der Phase des organistischen
militärischen Widerstands vorbei und die
Ukraine führt nur meinen Guerillakrieg
und diese leichten war von dir ein Mann
einsetzen und transportieren kann die
kann ich auch im Rahmen eines geringer
Kriegs zum Einsatz bringen
jetzt stehen wir vor einer anderen
Situation die Ukraine hat als
organisierter Widerstand als Staat und
Armee den ersten Ansturm überlebt und es
heißt wenn die russische Armee jetzt die
Schlachtung in dornbas gewinnt dann
würden nachher die Schlacht um karkiff
drankommen und danach die Schlachtung
und danach
von Süden hinauf wieder Richtung hier
und danach ist auch desto würde die
Westukraine immer noch stehen das heißt
selbst wenn Russland jetzt militärisch
die Siegerstraße finden würde würde es
noch Monate bis Jahre dauert ist
Russland diesen Krieg entschieden für
sich entschieden hätte das heißt auch
für langfristige
haben wir jetzt die Zeit gleichzeitig
und das ist aber die große Veränderung
zur Situation vor dem Krieg vor dem
Krieg hat die Ukraine die meisten
Waffensysteme selber herstellen können
Kampfpanzer in Cardiff mannschafts-
all diese Werke sind mittlerweile durch
russische Raketenangriffe zerstört
worden die gibt es nicht mehr das heißt
die Ukraine ist mit derselben Armee
heute viel mehr von ausländischen
Zulieferern abhängig weil die
entsprechenden Fabriken im eigenen Land
einfach nicht mehr existieren und
deshalb stehen wir da auch mit der
Anforderung der Ukraine was ist sie
gerne hätte für heute vor einer ganz
anderen Situation als zu Beginn des
Krieges wo die Ukraine wie gesagt die
meisten dieser Waffen die heute auf
Wunschlisten stehen einfach selber
gebaut hat
vielen Dank für Ihre Einschätzung und
Zeit heute abend Gustav gressel Militär
und Sicherheitsexperte vielen dank
vielen herzlichen Dank guten Abend
und natürlich behalten wir diese
Situation weiter im Auge die sich also
für die Menschen in der Ukraine vor
allem im Süden und Osten in den nächsten
Tagen und Wochen noch weiter zuzuspitzen
droht und wir sind natürlich jederzeit
wieder für euch live wann immer was
passiert bis dahin danke für eure
Aufmerksamkeit und tschüss